hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game I played between Arnold
Schwarzenegger and 12 year-old Michael
Kay it was played in the Arnold sports
festival in Melbourne Australia among
other sports there was also chess so
before the chess tournament started
Arnold decided to open the tournament by
playing a game against 12-year old
Michael and they played without clocks
as you'll see in this and not in the
description but as you'll see after the
video we do have a short clip of this
game so we are going to show it the the
game the moves the clip the the photos
everything was sent to me by a
subscriber mixtures but 87 who also runs
the YouTube channel of his own I will
put a link to his the YouTube and
Instagram account in the description
below so feel free to check it out it's
always a very nice when someone sends
you such a such a nice game but damn
without further ado let's check it out
Arnold has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 okay we have d5 by Michael I
will Knight to f3 by Arnold and c5
Michael goes for the Crofts variation
with D captures on c5 Arnold early leave
the center we have East six now
preparing to recapture with the Bishop
Knight to c3 and just Bishop captures on
c5 and Arnold wastes no time he attacks
the center we have a four you could
capture but you know not not something
black who really wants to do as Queen
captures Queen would not allow black the
castle anymore so d4 advancing the pawn
and attacking the knight on c3 we have
Knight the b5 preparing Bishop to f4
with this nice Knight the c7 check that
would pick up the rook nice to see six
black develops and now Arnold continues
with his plan with Bishop to f4 and now
of course the threat isn't Knight to c7
this will come with check so you do have
to prevent this
Michael stops this by playing Bishop to
b6 now the bishop also controls the c7
square and here there is a game that
continued Knights to d6 check and also
you could continue really a powerful
variation would be Bishop to c4 just
after black decides to go for four
castling now you go Knight to d6 check
and after the King moves Knight g5 and
others very little you can do to prevent
Knight captures on f7 it's it's just a
powerful attack by white but here Arnold
has a
different plan he goes Knight to e5 with
knife captures Bishop captures and now
f6 Knight the c7 shark is still not
possible and here Arnold's Bishop on e5
is under attack so what do you do here
Arnold was four nights to d6 check you
could just pick up the bishop both the
knight the bishop and the queen attack
the bishop but Arnold isn't interested
in going back he goes Knight to d6 with
check we have King t7 and now Knight
captures on c8 with check Arnold grabs
the bishop repair rook captures on c8
and now you could just move move the
bishop back let's say we go Bishop to a4
you keep the bishop pair and the game
continues but here we have a really
interesting move by Arnold he plays it
Bishop captures on d4 which doesn't
really make sense as well the the bishop
is attacked twice so here we have Queen
captures on d4 his younger adversary
just you know grabs the piece as Arnold
just left it hanging but it's hard to
imagine as if you've seen the game you
you saw that Arnold had a clear plan
Knight c3 not b5 before going for c7 and
here instead of just enjoying the
position he gives up a piece so this he
blundered the piece here or did he just
you know voluntarily gave up the
advantage to he's young get versary it's
hard to say but okay Queen captures
Queen captures Bishop captures and now
Arnold goes for queenside castle so
black is up a piece
Bishop to e5 and now g3 Arnold prepares
f4 we have knife to h6 Black has to
figure out how to bring the knight into
the game and now f4 attacking the bishop
Bishop to d6 and now it's well white
could go for something Bishop to b5
ideas let's say maybe then push key five
and maybe as the best controls d7 maybe
there there could be some tricks of rook
coming to d7
but here Arnold personal time he
immediately goes for a five sacrifice is
yet another pawn we have F captures on
e5 f captures on e5 knock'em special
captures on e5 and Bishop to h3 going
after the e6 pawn and now the other rook
is coming to e1 the bishop
have to move and the despawn will become
a target so Michael defends it
immediately will group the c6 defending
the knee six but also preparing to bring
the other rook and double up on the C
file with rook h t1 attacking the bishop
but now the bishop can move as the this
pawn is protected by the rook on d6 with
g4 Arnold just you know keeps on moving
forward
this is not no reverse gear Arnold rook
H to c8 doubling up here going for the
c2 pawn and now comes Luke to d2 you
have to defend it and here but c3 would
have been better as now black has an
opportunity to really punish white for
for his insolence of playing rook to d2
I'm sure you all see it without even
pausing the video it's Bishop to g5 just
pinning that rook there's no way to
prevent this so we have looked at e2 and
now here his opponent Michael captured
Bishop captures and e2 but is there
perhaps a better move than just
capturing the rook
feel free to pause the video and try to
find a better move here than just
capturing the rook I'll give you a
couple of seconds it's you know a very
nice idea for those of you who were able
to do it you were an excellent
checkmater in two moves which the rook
and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy so the rook is pinned as we
already mentioned so rook captures here
and now it doesn't really matter where
you go if you looking b1 or King d1 any
move you make rope to see one will be
checkmate so here you know Locke often
goes around as Arnold wonder the piece
so here his opponent doesn't doesn't go
for the immediate checkmate
he plays Bishop captures with rook
captures and now II five and this gives
Arnold an opportunity for a very nice
idea here Arnold goes g5 attacks the
night and h6 but also the rook and c8 so
just waiting for his you know
opportunity like like a true predator
predator now his opponent could play
something like Knight f7 give up the
exchange but he decides to preserve the
room we have looked to look 8 to see 7 g
captures on h6g chapters on h6 and now
Arnold just plays c3 rope captures on c2
will no longer be a trait and threat and
now this rook can finally move
we have King to f6 rook to ft check King
to g7 we have rook to f5 attacking the
pawn and rook to e7 putting a rope
behind a passed pawn Bishop to g4 and
now you have a loop behind the pass pawn
you have a passed pawn so now all that's
left is for you to pull the passed pawn
we have E for and outlook to F you're
preparing to block the pass born with
III rook three two and now look the g6
attacking the bishop we have h3 and now
rook to f6 is going for Rupe to f2 black
wants to exchange the rooks we have king
to see to look to f2 now offering this
this idea of course now it would be
impossible to prevent the queening of
the pawn you cannot go Bishop here as
the route controls that Square
so instead King to d3 and now of course
you cannot go checking in hopes of
grabbing the roof that way because King
can capture here but also that wouldn't
be possible for example if he played
this and King in fact capture here it
would be bad because yeah I mean I just
realized that the bishop is actually
attacking the rook so that's my bad but
yeah rook captures was played with rook
sorry King capture Sonny - and now comes
Luke to e4 we have bishop to have three
attacking the rook rook to e7 and now
just King to d3 we have came to g6 h4
and now comes King to f5 Arnold tries to
create a wall against the black King but
you know you just can't cover a 5 so we
have King to f5 and white King can't
really find any activity the white king
and the white bishop have to both keep
an eye on D 2 square so the point cannot
be pushed here we have c4 by Arnold King
to f4 attacking the bishop and now just
the Bishop to h5 again trying to create
a wall against the black King but you
can't cover all the squares we have King
to g3 and now King goes back to e2 King
captures Bishop back to f3 and now King
to g3 hoping to start pushing the past
pawns but you know you do have to cover
the h5 Square somehow perhaps the black
was hoping for Luke to e5 and then
pushing the pawn so Arnold just prevents
it with Bishop to h5 King 2h
for an Bishop to f3 Arnold down down to
ponds and the down the exchange would
definitely have nothing in you know
would not mind repeating moves and
reaching the draw but his opponent goes
now h5 the king is not protecting the
pawn
we have c5 by Arnold now finally
starting to push his own pawns King to
g5 making room for the pawn and now here
we have c6 before would have been a more
valiant attempt but we are gonna get
back to this here Arnold played c6
okay we have B captures Bishop captures
and c6 and now h4 the other passed pawn
is now starting to march forward push it
back to G 2 and now King to g4 and now
Bishop to f3 check King to g3 and Bishop
to b5 it seems like it might be better
to push the pawns here but it's it's all
the same
we have h3 Bishop to h1 now comes King
to h2 Bishop has to go back a bishop to
d5 King to g1 now the pawn can finally
be promoted on h1 Bishop to f3 and now
h2 arnold starts pushing the pawn we
have before with h1 Queen White has to
now capture Bushell capture screen
captures and now a for Arnold starts
pushing his pawns on the Queen side in
hopes of creating a passed pawn ah but
it is far too late for such things
kingi to was played b5 now with h5 by
black a5 now comes h4 b6 Arnold finally
creates a passed pawn on the Queen side
we have pawn captures pawn captures and
h3 and here you can no longer push the
pawn as the rookies protecting it but
Arnold has to play something so he goes
b7 we look at person b7 and here just
King captures on e3 and here after h2 it
was in this position that Arnold
Schwarzenegger resigned the game he
didn't want to wait for move 64 but yeah
a very nice game and I think this is the
first game ever that we have access to
the moves that that were played by
Arnold I was trying to find such a game
for a very long time as I know he plays
chess for almost his entire life but I
was enable
to do so so thank you very much makes us
/ 87 for sending me the moves the photos
and this video we're gonna check it out
os prove that the game did happen and
but also as it's just very enjoyable so
here it is for those of you who are
wearing headphones sorry about the sound
if it will be too loud I try to make it
you know enjoyable but we'll see so
here's the video this is the the end of
the game as you can see black makes the
room for the for the pawn Arnold tries
to create a spawn on the queenside and
here we have just yeah captures captures
h3 and there is nothing to be played
anymore I said there's a short clip I
have more of the footage but I only
decided to show this short amount but
yeah I know you guys always say you know
that's a funny game to show there better
games but yeah I always try to show our
games by celebrities as celebrities are
followed by a lot of people and if those
people see that they're the the person
they follow also plays chess then that
goes a long way in promotion of chess as
they will then think okay maybe chess is
something you know not just people with
waste their time on it maybe it's
something worth taking up and you know
maybe maybe they will try try chess as
well so yeah now I think it was a very
nice game first a really funny Alondra
by Arnold just that Bishop to d4 giving
up a piece but then opportunity
presented itself and he managed to grab
the night on h6 and continue playing
this game but I mentioned here in this
moment after King to g5 Arnold plates c6
I mentioned that a more valiant attempt
would have been before I mean you do
have a bishop your Bishop is controlling
h1 so it's not like the black can just
Queen the pawn so a possible scenario
would be like something like h4 b v h3 a
4 out let's say you go King to f4 you
have to bring the King into the game a 5
lets-a-go King g3 b 6 captures captures
and after let's say King 2h do you have
to bring your King to g2 g1 c6 captures
captures and now the black could easily
make make a mistake of going King to g1
just what we
the castle here you have to go look to
f7 bring the rook to f8 and control the
b8 that is now a dark square you cannot
protect it from a light square here in
black thought that maybe this would also
be winning he would be mistaken because
now b7 now you have to capture it as the
rookies Bishop is controlling this
square
so after captures captures you would
bring a queen enter game King captures
and now Bishop capture screen captures
and you are not queening this pawn the
White King is in time King f3 h5 King g3
and now you've just prevented the pawn
from Queen and King captures and perhaps
you know the game would end in the draw
it's a far-fetched idea but you know a
more valiant attempt than than c6 I
would say but yeah an interesting game
and like I said after h2 on will resign
the game and yeah that's it that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you are enjoying well this not not a
coverage but my choosing go over the
games like I said thanks a lot mister
mixes 87 for all of you who are
interested in his content I have put a
link in the description below the first
two links will lead you to his YouTube
channel and his Instagram page so do
check it out I would like to thank the
Dhammapada Juarez and release its Shan
and Roshan and Rima cuca and Lu guard
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the Capablanca saga most
likely we're going to the game
Capablanca versus Prokofiev thank you
all and I'll see you soon